نحن الان في مدينه حارم قرب الحدود
السوريه التركيه قبل قليل قال متطوع
الدفاع المدني السوري انهم سمعوا صوت
طفلين من داخل البناء المدمر لذلك عملوا
بشكل سريع على فتح نافذه بين الطوابق
الباتونيه وهم يحاولون الدخول الى داخل
البناء المدمر
لانتشال الطفلين يقولون ان ذلك العمل يجب
ان يتم بحذر شديد لان اي خطا يمكن ان يؤدي
بحياتهما لذلك فهم يتوقعون ان يطول العمل
حتى يتمكنوا من الدخول اليهم بامان هنا في
منطقه حارم تم الاستغناء عن الجرافات
الكبيره وحاليا يتم العمل بشكل يدوي طمعا
في الوصول الى ناجين تحت الانقاض فرق
الدفاع المدني ما زالت تعمل في منطقه
الاتارب وكذلك في منطقه بسنيا القريبه من
هنا حيث شهدت المنطقه اضرارا كبيره
صهيب الخلف الجزيره مدينه حارم ريف ادلب